Okay. So, good morning. We are
discussing the American Revolution
today. So, to review what we've done so
far, after the defeat of Napoleon um in
1815, there are now four major
civilizations that are competing against
each other for world
domination. Um last class we did the
British. Today we'll do the Americans.
Next week we'll do the Russians and the
Germans. Okay. So the Americans when you
think of America there's a very famous
quote from Oscar Wild who is a uh
English playright novelist humorist and
he
said America is the only country that
went from barbarism to decadence
violization in
between. Okay. So um he meant this as a
joke. So what did he mean by this? This
is a question we will discuss today. And
what I will show you is that America in
many ways it was designed as the
anti-ivilization. The founding fathers
of America recognized the failings and
problems of civilization and designed a
new form of government based on
enlightenment principles in order to
redeem humanity from the prejudices
um the atrocities of civilization. Okay.
So that's the argument we will look at
today. All right. So um the history of
the
Americas begins when the Europeans led
by the Spanish start to interact with a
new world. So the Spanish starting in
1492 they will come and conquer the
Aztecs, the Mayans and the Incas and
they will establish basically um
plantation economies where the Spanish
are extracting resources primarily gold,
silver uh from the uh Americas. They
will also establish sugar plantations on
the islands of the Caribbean and they
will man it with slaves from um Africa
as well as other places. And this is
extremely profitable for the Spanish. So
of course the English, the French and
the Dutch Republic, they want to get
they want to um get in on the action.
Okay. Okay. And at first they start to
smuggle
um resources into the new world and they
engage in piracy. In
1588 the English Navy defeats the SP
Spanish Amarda and this opens up the new
world now for the Europeans to come and
colonize it. Okay. The problem though is
that the Spanish control the best parts
of the new
world and so everyone else is stuck with
North America. And in North America
there's a few quite a few problems.
First of all, the weather is very cold.
Okay? So it's not um hospitable to
colonization. Second problem is that you
have lots of Native Americans in North
America who are extremely violent. They
are used to freedom and they will fight
to the death. Um at this time in history
the tallest strongest people in the
world are actually the native Americans
in North America. Um also you have lots
of um diseases that are problematic for
the Europeans. So um the Europeans spent
a lot of time basically decades in
trying to figure out how to best
colonize North
America. Um so there are three major
nations that are trying to colonize
North America. You have the French and
what they will do is they will establish
the fur trade in Canada and in the
Midwestern United States. They will
basically trade with the natives to
bring fur back to Europe. And this is a
great deal for both the natives and the
French. Uh the Dutch come in, they will
establish colonies uh colony new
Amsterdam. This is today New York City.
I said the Dutch tried to establish
colonies as well. The people who are
most successful at establishing colonies
are uh the British and a lot of it is
because it is a very grassroots very
bottomup movement. So the first major
colony for the British is Jamestown
named after um James the first of
Britain and this is not a very
successful colony at first but they
persist. The most successful colony is
actually Boston. What makes Boston
unique at this stage in North American
history is that it is established by a
co company the mass Massachusetts Bay
Company that is a that has a charter
from the English crown. Also they bring
in
families into this area. So um before it
was basically men who came over now it's
families who come over.
Um and then third of all the people who
come over are Puritans. Puritans um as
we discussed previously they believe in
the importance of literacy. Everyone has
responsibility to read the Bible in
order to interpret um the the command of
God properly. And so Boston from the
very beginning it's a literate society.
It has schools. It has newspapers. Um it
is very political and it grows very very
fast. Also, if you look at Boston, it is
perfectly situated between North America
and England. And as England is
industrializing, it requires raw
resources, mainly agricultural products
from this area. Okay. So, Boston grows
rapidly because of all these factors. Um
so in the year 1682 you can see that the
eastern United States has been colonized
by the British. Okay. The French are
still in um Canada and they're going to
move down to the Midwest United States.
The Spanish are in the southern United
States. This is Florida. They found a
colony called St. Augustine. They will
also in California start to um build
colonies as well. But as you can see the
the most of the economic activity in
North America is based on the eastern
seabboard. Now um what's really
important for us to remember is the
diversity of these colonies. First of
all you have differences in in economy.
The northern part will focus mostly on
mercantile trade. The southern part will
focusing mo mostly on agriculture. to
support the agriculture. They will
import slaves from Africa in order to um
provide the labor for Charle Town and
other places. Also, the motivations of
the individuals are different. So, some
come for economic reasons, but a lot
come for religious purposes. So, for
example, there's a man named William
Penn and he's a Quaker. He believes in
creating a peaceful civilization. So he
has a charter from the king and he
creates he founds a new colony called
Pennsylvania named after him that
believes in religious and national
tolerance. So a lot of Germans come over
and settle down in Pennsylvania. The
capital is Philadelphia and they are
Quakers. So they believe they must not
fight against others. Okay? And this
experiment persists for decades. Okay?
It's it's a pretty successful
experiment. But over time they come into
conflict with the natives and with other
civilizations with other colonies and as
such they start to take up arms. Okay.
Um there's another colony called
Baltimore. It was founded actually as a
Catholic uh haven. Okay. So England at
this point it is mainly Protestant or
Puritan or Anglican. Um and then Lord
Baltimore decides to in Maryland found a
new colony that that preaches religious
tolerance especially for Catholics.
Okay. So what's really important for us
to remember is that even at this early
stage in American history, um there's
tremendous diversity, openness, and
religious tolerance in uh America. Okay,
does that make sense? All right. So um
by the year 5
1750, there are about a million British
on the eastern seabboard. That's a lot
of people. Okay. In comparison, the
French who occup who occupy actually
most of the territory in North America,
there's only 40,000. Eventually, these
two groups, the British and the French
will come into conflict, creating
something called the French and Indian
Wars. Okay? And as you can see, it's not
really it's really not a fair fight.
Okay? You got a million British versus
40,000 French. the Indians will get
involved as well because what's
happening is the the these colonies are
practicing a rapid form of colonization
and expansion. What they do is they
bring in immigrants then um as the
population uh uh explodes these
immigrants will be forced to move out
west to settle territory in the western
uh frontier of the of of these colonies.
But as as you know these these areas are
uh inhabited by Native Americans and so
this brings the Indians into conflict
with the British as well. So um the
resolution to this is that King George
III will
proclaim that the American colonists are
not allowed to move westwards of the App
Appalachian Mountains. Okay. So he's
restricting the growth of
um the American colonies in order to
maintain friendship with the
natives. And obviously the Americans
don't like that. So in
1774 there are three major issues that
bring the American colonist into
conflict with the English crown. Okay.
The first is as I just mentioned the
English crown is limiting the expansion
of the colonies
westwards and they don't like that.
Okay. Second um is that it's very it was
very expensive for the British to
protect the colonies against the French
and the Indians. In fact, at this stage
in history, it is the British people,
not the American people, that are paying
for the defense of these colonies. In
fact, the British people pay 50 times
more in taxes than the Americans. Now,
obviously, the the uh British people
don't actually think this is a fair
deal. All right? So uh the British crown
tries in many instances to impose a tax
in order to in order to get the
Americans to pay for the defense of
their territory and the Americans don't
like that. Uh for the longest time
because of the English civil war and
other factors the English crown could
not actually interfere in uh North
American affairs and so they were used
to a high level of autonomy. Okay. And
the third major problem between the
colonists and the British is in trade.
So at this stage in history all these
nations Spain, France, Britain, they're
practicing a economic policy called
mercantalism. Okay, mercantalism is the
idea that all trade should be directed
by the state for the purpose of
generating wealth for the state. And so
what this means is that there are
different trade zones that are
established in competition with each
other. And so if you are a British
subject, you're only allowed to trade
with other British lands. Okay? So the
Americans can trade with England and
with India, but they're not allowed to
trade with the French and the Dutch and
the Spanish. And the Americans don't
really like this either. Okay? So these
are the three main factors driving
division between the American colonist
and the British crown. And this will of
course culminate in the American
Revolution. Okay, the war of
independence of
1776. Also what's really important for
us to remember at this time is that per
capita, the Americans are far
wealthier than the British. Okay, now
this is strange and you ask yourself why
is it that even though England is
industrializing far more rapidly than
the Americans and there are more uh
British citizens than Americans and also
Britain is an empire whereas America is
a colony. How is it that the Americans
per capita are able to become wealthier
than the British? And the answer has to
do with the American work ethic, the
American attitude towards life. And this
is best expressed by a man named
Benjamin Franklin, okay? Who is
considered one of the founding fathers
of America. He is um he he had an
incredible life. He was born poor but
through hard work through tenacity
through optimism
um he was able to become a merchant a
very wealthy merchant and an inventor a
philosopher an ambassador a politician
okay so he is basically the role model
for Americans towards the end of his
life he wrote his
autobiography and so we're going to
study his autobiography in order to get
insight into the mentality
of the average American at this stage in
history. Okay.
Now, Benjamin Franklin by running by
writing his memoir, he starts a new fad
in America that persists to today. It's
called the self-improvement or self-help
uh fad and and these are the best these
are the books that sell the most in
America. So, you may have heard of how
to win friends and influence people by
Dale Carnegie. There's also Napoleon
Hill, Think and Grow Rich. Okay. And
these books are just telling you how to
as as as they say how to be more
successful in life. Okay. This is called
the self-help movement. And the
Americans really pioneered this. Before
in history, no one believed that for
your hard work you can actually attain
more in life. And in fact, you must uh
go up and obtain more in life. Okay. So,
the Americans really start this
self-help uh fad. All right. So let's
read certain passages from the
autobiography of Benjamin Franklin to
gain insight into the American
psychology. Okay. From the bosom of
poverty and obscurity. So he was born
poor. He was born a nobody in which I
drew my first breath and spent my
earliest years. I've raised myself to a
state of opulence and to some degree of
celebrity in the world. This is the
American dream. You can be born poor but
through hard work you can become rich.
Okay. A constant good fortune has
attended me through every period of life
to my present advanced age. And my
descendants may be desirous of learning
what were the means of which I made use
and which thanks to the assisting hand
of providence have proved so imminently
successful. They may also should they
ever be placed in a similar situation
derive some advantages from my
narrative. Okay. So, not only is going
to tell you how he be how to become
rich, but he will teach you how to
become rich. Okay? So, if you just do
what he does, you'll become rich as
well. So, this is the American optimism.
This is American
dream. All
right. So, he
continues. He's talking to a friend and
his friend tells him, "Your writing
sucks."
And at this time he should be angry,
right? But instead he recognizes
that look there's merit in my friend's
criticism. So so I will improve myself.
Okay. Um and the way he improves himself
and he and he writes it. I won't read it
because it's too long. But he what he
does is this. He takes a magazine, a
spectator which is very well written and
then he summarizes the main points of
the articles that he's read. Then he
will take the summary and he will
rewrite the article from memory himself.
And then he will compare and contrast
his work with that of the original work.
And then he will make adjustments and
refinements to his own writing. Okay.
Now um if you if you actually know how
to write and if you actually met good
writers, writers don't write like this.
Okay. This is not how you learn how to
read and write. But again, this shows us
the
optimism of the American
character that through just pure hard
work and tenacity and persistence, you
can learn anything. Even though um
historically we all know that writers
are people of genius, they're sort of
born great writers. Okay? You're not
going to learn how to be a man of genius
just through pure imitation. Okay? But
what he's telling us is that no is that
no through imitation you can improve
yourself. Okay, that's a very American
outlook. All
right. Now he's going to tell us how I
became rich. I began to pay by degrees
the debt I had contracted. And in order
to ensure my credit and character as a
tradesman, I took care not only to be
really industrious and frugal, but also
to avoid every appearance of the
contrary. I was plainly dressed and
never seen any place of public
amusement. Okay, so this is this he's
telling you how he became rich. First of
all, he was honest. When he did
business, he made sure that he never
tricked anyone. Okay, his reputation
mattered above all. Also, he dressed in
a very simple way. He didn't waste any
money. He he came across to everyone as
someone who was a good Christian, a good
Calvinist, someone who enjoyed making
money and someone who saved all his
money uh in pursuit of the praise of
God. Okay? And this is how you become
rich in America, right? And you can
imagine that um there is merit to what
he says that if you do work hard, if you
are honest and if you save a lot of
money, then it's possible for you to
become rich. Okay? And this is the
common mentality right now at this stage
in America. Okay. He
continues, I ought to have related that
during the autumn of the preceding year,
I united the majority of well-informed
persons of my acquaintance into a club
which we call by the name of the Chunto
and an object of which was to improve
our understandings. Okay, this is really
important. What he's telling us is that
after he became rich, he met other rich
people and they formed a philosophy club
to debate and discuss the political
issues of the day. It was like it was
like a book club. Okay. They read John
Lock um they read Thomas Hobbs and and
they discussed these ideas. So this is a
quintessential American attitude,
constant
self-improvement. Okay, you you can
become the wealthiest man in the world,
but you still must read books. Also this
is important because these book clubs
will become the foundation of the
American revolution. Right? These
founding fathers will meet in these
clubs and they will conspire to seek
independence from the United from
Britain. Now a lot of a lot of it is
they believe that providence God has
tasked them with founding a new nation
based on enlightenment principles. So
the religion of these people is what we
call dism. Okay. Uh d e i s m and the
idea of dism that's very different from
previous religions is they believe there
is a god and god created the universe
but after that god went away and now it
is the responsibility of humans to make
the world
perfect. Okay that's the mission from
god. All right. This was the best school
for politics and philosophy that then
existed in the province. For our
questions which were read once a week
previous to the discussion induced us to
peruse attentively such books as were
written upon the subjects proposed that
we might be able to speak upon them more
permanently. Okay. So they know that
providence has tasked them with creating
a great nation called America. And to
understand how to do so they will read
all the books of integrity. They will
study Rome. They will study Athens,
Sparta, Carthage. They will study the
Dutch Republic. They will study the
British Constitution. Okay? And by
studying these these um um classics,
they will come to a consensus on how to
build a new society
um in the image of God. Okay, does that
make sense? Okay, this is the foundation
of the American Revolution.
All right. So, um, not only did America
became very wealthy very fast through
the hard work, simplicity, and optimism
of the people, but as you can see from
this map, they basically spread out
really quickly. At this time in history,
the Spanish, the British, the French are
all in North America. The Russians are
here as well. But over time, the
Americans will push everyone out. And
this is what what they call manifest
destiny.
Okay. All right. So
1776 America declare de declares
independence from Britain and again this
is this is after years and years of
conflict uh over a myriad of issues.
Thomas Jefferson
uh one of the founding fathers he writes
something called the declaration of
independence. Why is America declaring
independence from Britain? And the
answer
is we hold these truths to be
self-evident that all men are created
equal. That they are endowed by the
creator with certain unaliable rights.
That among these are life, liberty, and
the pursuit of happiness. That to secure
these rights, governments are instituted
among men, deriving their just powers
from the consent of the govern. that
whenever any form of government becomes
destructive of these ends, it is the
right of the people to alter or to
abolish it. Okay guys, Thomas Jefferson
in writing the declaration of
independence which is the founding
document of the United States. He is
just copying word for word basically
John Lock spoke the second treaties of
government. Okay, this is this is what
John Lock said. We are born with three
fundamental rights that God has given us
and therefore no one can take away from
us. the right to life, liberty, and the
pursuit of
property. Government is instituted,
created in order to protect our rights.
If government fails to protect these
rights, then we have a responsibility
and a right to abolish this government
and create a new one.
Okay. All right. So, there's the war of
independence and the great hero of this
war, of course, is George Washington.
Why Americans rever um so can you open
the door? Why Americans revere George
Washington is that it's not how great he
was during the war. Um because
ultimately the Americans didn't actually
defeat the British. It was the French,
the Spanish who combined together to
defeat the British. Um and eventually
the British decided that you know what
the Americans colonist they're too much
pro they're too problematic we don't
really care okay so let's just focus on
Europe so um the Americans fought a
guerilla warfare and they were very
brave but without the French the uh the
Americans could not possibly have
defeated the the British. Okay. So, but
what made George Washington so esteemed
uh in the hearts of the American people
is after this war, he retired. Okay? He
just went back to his farm and enjoyed
uh his last years in the garden. And
that's why Americans worship him because
he's a man who could have become king of
America, but instead he chose to um
grant Americans their freedom and
independence. Okay.
Um the ada comp of George Washington the
genius of American revolution is
actually a Hamilton. He is the really
the founder of America. He's really the
one who has the vision of what of where
America could go of where what America
could be. Okay. His name is Alexander
Hamilton and he is in conflict with
Jefferson. These two individuals
represent two competing uh strands of
America after uh the war of
independence. For Thomas
Jefferson, what's important is to
maintain the inelable individual rights
of the individuals. He wants a
democracy. And because most people are
farmers at this point, um he believes
economic policies should be focused on
agriculture. Okay. So this is a Thomas
Jefferson Thomas Jefferson uh ideals of
the American Revolution. Hamilton saw
the world differently. He believed in
his heart as in did many people at this
time America is destined to be a empire
and therefore it needs a strong central
government and in order to become an
empire it must have industry. Okay. So
um some certain points um so the
colonists are fighting the British for
because uh the British are trying to tax
them, the British are trying to impose
an army on them and because the British
are trying to to limit their trade.
Okay. So in order to get everyone to
fight they create something called the
Articles of
Confederation which limits the power of
the government to impose taxes which
limits the ability of the government to
raise troops. But this is
problematic
because you can't actually fight a war
like this. Okay. So, um after the
British leave and leave America alone,
problems start to arise. Basically, the
main problem is you have lots and lots
of soldiers who used to be farmers. They
were promised pay when they joined the
militia against the British. But because
government has no money, they had no
money. Okay? And they're also farmers
and because they had to leave their
farms they fell into debt and so rich
people came and took took over their
farms and this led to something called
the Shaes rebellion where farmers are
now trying to overthrow the government.
And so the solution was to create
something called the constitution which
would grant more power to the central
government especially to um collect
revenue to control trade foreign trade
and to have a army basically. Okay. So
that that was the solution uh that
proposed by Hamilton and his friends.
Jefferson argued that this would of
course limit the rights of individuals.
So he insisted on adding something
called the bill of rights to the
constitution. Okay, you may have heard
something called the first amendment,
the second amendment, uh the right to
speak freely, the right to bear arms.
This is a this is from the bill of
rights. It's actually not in the
constitution. The constitution is a
framework for how to build a strong
central government. Okay. Second thing I
want you guys to um um understand is
agriculture and industry. It's a it's a
different framework, okay? It's a
different economic framework. With
agriculture, you need a lot of slave
labor because obviously you need people
to uh man the fields and grow the crops.
Okay? And that's why um if you want to
have agriculture, you have you have to
bring actually a lot of slave labor from
Africa. But if you focuses on industry,
you don't want slave labor. You want
free labor. Okay? You want the market to
decide who does what job and how much
they get paid. This is a much more
efficient way to organize your economy.
If you are industrializing and the
reason why is when you're
industrializing you need specialized
labor, okay, you need differentiation of
skills and the market is the best
mechanism for um skills to be
differentiated and to be rewarded. Okay,
also think about this.
If you got really sick, okay, you you
need heart surgery. Would you rather go
to a doctor
um who's a slave or a doctor who's going
to charge you a million dollars, right?
So, um free labor just allows for more
economic activity and therefore more
wealth generation in society. All right?
So, these are two competing visions of
where America should be headed. And of
course, this is a contradiction. Okay?
You can't have slave labor and free
labor at the same time. The north goes
uh implements a policy of free labor.
The south maintains policy of slave
labor because they are mainly an
agricultural
uh uh society. Ob obviously Jefferson is
from the south. Hamilton is from New
York. This conflict will eventually give
rise to the American Civil War of 1861.
Okay. So this conflict has always been
there. But in 1789 when they introduced
the constitution they choose to ignore
this conflict until 1861 when this
conflict finally led to violence. Okay.
So this is the root of the American
civil war. Does it make sense
guys? All right. Okay. Now let's look at
the constitution. The constitution is
meant to be the most perfect form of
government ever
established. Okay. America is a clean
slate. It's a tabala Russa. can the
Americans do what can do whatever they
want. So they study all the previous
republican uh democratic monarchal
aristocratic systems and they decide to
imitate um Monuscu. Monscu was a French
thinker who believed in idea of
separation of powers. If you want to
create a perfect government you need to
have you need to balance the different
factions of society using separation of
powers. Okay. So um the American system
is you have three different branches of
government. You have the president who
controls
um the military as for as well as
foreign policy. Then you have the
congress which controls the purse the
financing of government. You have the
supreme court which um interprets the
constitution which interprets the
highest law of the land. And so if done
properly what will happen
is these three branches of government
will balance each other out. They're
meant to be counts and balances.
Okay. The each is meant to inhibit the
overextension of the other. Okay. That
is the American system of government. Uh
that is basically uh stolen from
Monuscu. All right. The other uh check
check and balance is the division
between federal Washington DC the state
level individual states and the local
level. Okay. So the responsibilities of
each is defined very clearly and the
idea is that um they should also balance
each other out. Okay. This contrasts of
course with the Chinese system where you
just have one uh person in charge and he
has something called the pilot barrel
underneath him. The pilot barrel then
then appoints everyone into the um
government as well as the army as well
as the provincial and local governments.
Okay. So it's a very top- down system
whereas the American system is meant to
be a balanced system. Okay. Does that
make
sense? All
right. So the problem now is now that
you've decided that you need a
constitution, you need a federal
government, how do you convince the
people to go along with this? because
for the constitution to go in effect all
13 states have to agree to the
constitution by a twothirds uh majority.
Okay. So to convince people um Alexand
Hamilton, James Madison and John J write
something called the federalist papers.
The federalist papers are a series of
pamphlets series of newspaper articles
that explain why the constitution is
necessary. Okay. So let's um so we're
going to look at a few passages. All of
them are written by A Hamilton who is
really again the genius of the
constitution. The one who is really
driving the need for a strong central
government in order to facil facilitate
America's imperial ambitions. All right.
As this government is composed of small
republics and enjoys internal happiness
of each and respect to its external
situation. It is possessed by means of
the association of all the advantage of
large monarchies. Okay. So this idea of
a mixed balanced government where you
are trying to take the advantage
advantage of all political systems
within America it will be a republican
system. Okay. And so you will enjoy
within your area democracy. But at a
national level in relation to other
states, it will be a monarchy where the
president represents the nation in
discussions and negotiations and
conflicts with the other great European
nations.
Okay. All right.
Another um thing that the uh
constitution does is if the president
wants to appoint ministers, if the
government if if the president wants to
appoint officials, they have to be
vetted and approved by the senate. Okay?
And this is this is new. Uh usually a
king can appoint who whoever he or she
wants. But in the constitution, the
senate must vet everyone. And the idea
of this is to create accountability and
transparency within government. Okay. So
Hamilton explains this to what purpose
then require the cooperation of the
Senate? I answer that the necessity of
their concurrence would have a powerful
though in general asylent operation. It
would be an excellent check upon a
spirit of favoritism in the president
and would tend greatly to prevent the
appointment of unfick characters from
state prejudice, from family connection,
from personal attachment or from a view
to popularity. Okay, let's just say the
president wants to appoint his son to be
the secretary of state. Okay, the son
appears before the Senate and it's like
a job interview and the son is an idiot.
He doesn't know anything. Okay, so in
this instance, the son has embarrassed
the president and it's this fear of
being embarrassed that inhibits the
president from abusing his powers. Okay,
that's a theory. Okay, does that make
sense? And and over actually over the
course of American history, it's worked
very very well. Okay, they power public
opinion. It's very very strong. But
what's important for us to remember is
all this is based on the idea of
convention on norms on values. As long
as people buy into these conventions and
norms, the system will work. But if
you're someone like Donald Trump who
does not buy into these norms and
values, it may be a problem. Okay. Okay.
So, we'll see what happens over the next
few years.
All right. These judicious reflections
contain a lesson of moderation to all
the sincere lovers of the union and
ought to put them upon their guard
against hazarding anarchy, civil war, a
perpetual alienation of the states from
each other, and perhaps the military
despatism of victorious demagogue. Okay,
let me explain what this means. What
this is saying is this. Agent Hamilton,
what he's saying is this. In creating a
government, we're not we're not trying
to aspire to greatness. We're trying to
prevent collapse. This is risk
management. We're trying to avoid the
risk of government. Okay. What's the
risk of government? Well, you could have
anarchy where people reject the
government. You have civil war where the
states go to war against each other. You
could have a perpetual alienation of the
states from each other, division within
the government, and then military
desperatism where tyrant arises. Okay?
So, the point of the constitution is
risk management. It's to prevent America
from
failing. All right. All right. So, um at
the constitution, America uh now embarks
on something called manifest destiny.
The idea of manifest destiny is it's the
will of God for America to conquer and
settle the entire western
hemisphere. Okay? North America, South
America, it's all America because that
is the will of God. So today Trump is
saying how America should annex Canada
and as well as Greenland. That's part of
manifest destiny. It's not
new. All
right. All right. This leads to 1823
something called the Monroe Doctrine. So
President Monroe um before Congress he
announces that from now on the Europeans
are not allowed to
interfere in the Western Hemisphere. the
western hemisphere is entirely
American. Okay. So he says Europe are
henceforth not to be considered as
subjects for future colonization by any
European powers. The Western Hemisphere
is henceforth not to be considered as
subjects for future colonization by any
European powers. Hey guys, Russia,
France, Germany, Britain, Spain, forget
the Western Hemisphere. It's our
territory. You come over here and we'll
beat the crap out of you. Okay?
All right. So um now America to achieve
its manifest destiny it needs to expand.
Okay. And it uses multiple strategies to
expand. In 1803 remember the mid west in
the United States it's controlled by
France. It basically buys all this from
Napoleon. Okay. So now it's extending
outwards over to here. Of course there
are there are natives in these
territories. So what the Americans do,
of course, is eradicate the the natives.
It's a war of
genocide. All right. Um, War of 1812 is
when America and Canada come into
conflict. Again, because of manifest
destiny, America sees Canada as part of
of its territory, but the British don't
agree. And this leads to a war of 1812.
It's a stalemate. Okay? And after a
stalemate, basically the British and
Americans agree that Canada will stay a
British
uh colony. But
uh again because of manifest destiny, we
can expect America to eventually take
over Canada as well as
Greenland. Um 1846 the Mexican-American
War. So America fights a war with Mexico
and takes over Texas as well as
California. Okay. Basically the entire
western part of the United States is now
incorporated into
uh the new nation. Um this in 1861 we
have the Civil War. All right. All
right. And I've already explained the
causes of the Civil War. Right? This
conflict between Thomas Jefferson and
Hamilton, the two visions for where
America is going will eventually lead us
to the American Civil War. You may have
learned that the American Civil War was
about slavery. It was not about slavery.
It was mainly about state rights. Okay?
It was really about democracy versus
empire. In a democracy, the states can
do whatever they want. But in an empire,
the central government is able to
dictate a lot of policy. Okay? So
eventually this will lead to the civil
war and of course the north wins the
civil war because the north is um far
more industrial far more wealthier and
powerful than the south and and so the
Hamilton vision is now achieved. It will
it will be expanded throughout the
western hemisphere. There's a problem
though. The problem is this. Um, so at
this time of course Abraham Lincoln is
president of the United States and he's
considered the greatest president in
American history for a reason. The
reason is this. The Civil War was the
deadliest war in American history. Okay,
let's let's look at this. Over 600,000
people died in the American Civil War,
which is about four years. Um, only
400,000 died in World War
II, right? The problem is this. In 1861,
the population of America at this time
was 30 million people. World War II, the
population was 130 million. So, this was
by far the deadliest war in American
history. Brothers were killing brothers.
It was a tremendous um um there I mean
it was such a bloody conflict. And so
after this war was
ended, everyone was asking why did we do
this? What's the point of this? And so
there was shock. Um there was anger.
There was frustration. So Abraham
Lincoln now has to stand up and explain
why this happened, why did this war
happen, right? He needs to form a new
vision of America that binds people
together, that creates a new union.
Okay? Okay. So he presents this new
vision in something called the Gettsburg
address which is considered the greatest
speech in American history. Okay. This
is 1863. Uh the battle of Gildersburg
was one of the bloodiest war bloodiest
battles in the American Civil War. And
he and we're going to read all of it.
Okay. It's because it's a very short
speech and it's very powerful.
Four score and 70 years. Seven years
ago, our fathers brought forth on this
calendar a new nation conceived in
liberty and dedicated to the proposition
that all men are created equal. All
right. So the war of independence, it
was not a
war to seek independence from Britain.
It was a revolution in human
affairs. It was about bringing liberty
to the world. Okay? It was about
creating a new civilization.
Now we're engaged in a great civil war
testing whether that nation or any
nation so conceived and so dedicated can
long endure. Okay. So the American
Revolution it is an experiment in the
possibilities of human liberation and
the civil war it is meant to destroy
this experiment. So we must persist in
this
experiment. We are met on a great
battlefield of that war. Gettysburg. We
have come to dedicate a portion of that
field as a final resting place for those
who here gave their lives that the
nation might live. It is altogether
fitting and proper that we should do
this.
Okay. But in a larger sense, we cannot
dedicate, we cannot consecrate, we
cannot hollow this ground. The sacrifice
of the man is what has made this land
sacred. The sacrifice of these of these
men is what made our nation um is what
makes our nation sacred. It's what saves
our nation. The brave men living and
dead who struggled here have consecrated
it far above our poor power to add or
detract. The world with little note nor
long remember what we say here. But it
can never forget what they did here. It
is for us the living rather to be
dedicated here to the unfinished work
which they who fought here have thus far
so nobly
advanced. Okay. And this ends it. It is
rather for us to be here dedicated to
the great task remaining before us that
from these honored dead we take
increased devotion to the cause for
which they here gave the last full
measure of devotion. The men are dead.
There's nothing we can do to resurrect
them. It is the responsibility of us the
living to honor the sacrifice and to
continue the mission that they died for
which to spread liberty throughout the
world to bring liberty into human
civilization. That we here highly
resolve that these dead shall not have
died in vain. That this nation under God
shall have a new birth of freedom and
that government of the people by the
people for the people shall not perish
from the earth.
Okay. So the so again with Hamilton it's
about empire for Jefferson it's about
democracy. There's a conflict right?
What Lincoln does which is revolution is
say no this is not a conflict because we
are an empire of
democracy. We are born in liberty. We
fight for liberty and we will spread
liberty. All right. So this is a new
concept in American history. Not only
not so now America is not confined to
the north
hemisphere. It has responsibility to
honor the dead honor sacrifice by
creating liberty throughout the world to
create a new chapter in human
civilization. Okay, that's the purpose
of this speech to heal America by
reminding them of their divine mission
to spread democracy and truth throughout
the world. All right, so after Civil
War, America is now industrializing
rapidly. 1867 it buys Alaska from
Russia. Um
1898 America fights the Spanish and they
take over the Spanish colony. So now
America has become an imperial power.
All right. America now controls the
Philippines as well as Cuba. Then um
World War I, America goes and defeats
Germany. World War II is when America
becomes
um the global hedgeimon of the world and
then after Soviet Union fell uh we now
live in something called the PAX
Americana. Okay, America is the greatest
power in the world. They have completed
Lincoln's vision of becoming an empire
of democracy. We now live in the empire
of democracy. All right. But now the
question then is what is an empire of
democracy? What is that? And so we go
back to Oscar Wild's quote, "America is
not a civilization." All right? And what
does he mean by that? To understand
this, we have to read another book
called Democracy in America by a
Frenchman named Alexe Detoqueville. This
is the most famous book ever written
about America. Okay? Not by American,
but by a French man who visited America
for maybe eight months. In 1835, he
publishes Democracy in America. and he's
trying to explain why is it that
American democracy works and why is it
and why is it destined to eventually
conquer the
world. All right. Um now there's a lot
of debate about this book. Uh hopefully
you'll be able to read this book um in
college. It is a fantastic book. It's
really one of the best books ever
written. Um and it's a thousand pages.
So it's possible for you to interpret
the book in many different ways.
But what I want to show you today is
extoil actually is skeptical about
American democracy. He is actually um
afraid of what the spreading American
liberty will mean for the world. Okay.
So the argument I will show you is
America is really the first mass
democratic middle class country. Okay.
But because of that the people there are
selfish conformist and
unimaginative. and he fears that as
America conquers the world the world
will become atomized, uniform and
mediocre. Atomized just means that we
live in our own little bubble. We don't
really care about larger issues than
than ourselves. Uh uniform means
everyone thinks the same way and
mediocre means that well no one's
striving for greatness anymore. If you
think about it, okay, the world we live
in today in the year
2025, this is the world we live in. It's
a atomized uniform and mediocre world.
So how did this happen? How was it
possible for the world to become like
this? And for for you to understand
this, it's important to go back to the
Dutch Republic. We discussed Dutch
Republic last week and talk about what
it means to be middle class. Now, as I
said last week, the middle class is
distinct because it creates anxiety,
uncertainty, and competition within the
lives of individuals. Okay? Anxiety
comes from the fact that your situation
is never stable. You could be rich
tomorrow, but you could be poor the next
day. This is different from history
where if you're born poor, you stay
poor. If you're a noble person, you
could have no money, but your status
stays with you. Okay? Right? And it goes
passes on to your children and your
grandchildren. Okay? So there's a
certainty in that
world. Um but in this world, if you're
middle class, you could be a factory
owner, you could be jack, and then the
next day you get unlucky and you lose
all your money. Okay? You're back to
being a poor person. This creates
anxiety and uncertainty. Also, because
um status is not given, but it must be
earned. There's competition among middle
class members to strive for status.
Okay? Okay. And this creates something
we call OCD, obsessivecompulsive
disorder. And it leads to an obsessive
control of yourself. Uh a focus on
cleanliness and a desire to accumulate
and achieve. Okay? And if you think
about it, we discuss the the memoir of
Benjamin Franklin, right? Well, why is
he focused on such a simple living? Why
is he focused on earning so much money?
Why does he constantly want to achieve?
It's because of the anxiety of being
middle class. You're born poor. You get
you you you earn a lot of money. You
become wealthy. But how do you know you
won't become poor? How do you know your
children won't become poor? The only way
to resolve this anxiety is by constantly
accumulating more and more.
Okay. All right. So let's um look at
democracy in America. Okay. Okay, let's
look at certain passage passage in about
um let's look at certain passages from
democracy in America to understand the
thinking of the toqueville. All
right, such a democratic society would
be less brilliant than aristo
aristocracy but also less plagued by
misery. Pleasures would be less extreme,
prosperity more general. Knowledge would
be less exalted but ignorance more rare.
Feelings would be less passionate and
habits milder. there will be more vices
and fewer crimes. Okay, this is actually
a hard passage to understand. So what
he's seeing is this.
Intolic societies, in most societies,
there's a huge gap between the rich and
the poor. Okay? And there's a huge gap
between the great and the mediocre. What
democratic societies do is they take
this system and they turn it into this
system. Okay? So the middle class um
they're not that great, but they're not
that poor either. Okay, they're not as
talented, but they're not as mediocre.
Okay, so you've you've taken the system,
right? And you turn it into this system.
And that's a theory of democracy. And in
theory, this sounds better. Okay? If you
if you're just born uh randomly into a
democ democratic society, you are much
more likely to live a happy life than if
you were born into an aristoic society.
Okay? So that's a
theory,
but the Toko spent a lot of time looking
America and he and he decided that's not
what happened. Okay. It's not that you
went from this to this. It's like you
went from this to like this.
Okay. All right. So, he
explains, but what have we done in
rejecting the social state of our
ancestors and casting aside the
institutions, ideas, and moors? What
have we put in their place? So, what
he's saying is the American Revolution
was about destroying tradition, about
destroying civilization, but they failed
to build new traditions and new
civilization.
The prestige of world power has
evaporated but the majesty of the law
has failed to take its place. Okay, this
is key. Um before we worship a man, a
king and the king made us um obedient to
his law. We got rid of the king and we
said well uh let's keep the law. The
problem is this. The problem is people
respect and rever those who are
superior to them. They do not respect
and revere ideas and things and laws.
Does that make sense? Okay. So, in
theory, America is a rule of law nation,
but people don't really understand these
laws and people don't rever these laws
as much as they would a superior
man. It strikes me that we have
destroyed those individual who once have
the law to battle tyranny on their own.
So in a erratic system what will happen
is you will is you have these great
individuals like ropes PR emerge to
challenge the system and he feels um and
he's supported by others because others
see the injustice of the system but in
democracy what happens is great
individuals are oppressed by the
conformity the tyranny of majority okay
does that make
sense right if everyone's happy then you
say but if you come out and you say
listen this system is wrong people will
shut you
down right inocracy everyone knows
what's unjust so if you come out and you
speak speak what's unjust people will
follow you in a democracy in middle
middle class society which is conformist
you're you're not allowed to question
popular opinion and therefore no great
man can arise if you think about it in
American history there aren't that many
great individuals
Okay, it's a great country. It's very
wealthy. Um, but think about how many
great individuals who have arisen.
What's also unique about America is the
people they worship are not generals,
not leaders, but business people. Henry
Ford, Ellen
Musk, Thomas Edison, right? These are
all business people. That's who they
worship.
The poor man for the most part clings to
his forebears prejudices without their
faith and to their ignorance without
their
virtues. Okay. So the Catholic Church
was problematic. Medieval Europe was
problematic. But at least people knew
how to live a good life. Now if you're a
poor person, you're completely lost in
the
system. Okay? You're expected to have
your own virtues. You're expected to
discover your own purpose in life. But
if you don't then you're alienated.
Okay. And this creates a huge problem uh
that we'll discuss later on. All right.
He continues, I see men who in the name
of progress seek to reduce men to
material being. This is the ultimate
problem in America. Before in
civilization, you were asked to die for
your nation. Now you're asked to go make
money and buy things. Okay. Materialism.
They look for what is useful without
concern for what is just. They seek
science removed from faith and
prosperity apart from virtue. Having
style themselves champions of modern
civilization, they have arrogantly
placed themselves at its head, usurping
a position abandoned by others which
they are quite unworthy of occupying
themselves. Okay. So in this system, the
worst rise to power, the best are
trampled down by conformity.
All
right. All right. He continues, "I'm
trying to imagine what new features
despatism might have in today's world. I
see an innumerable host of man all alike
and equal endlessly hastening after
petty and vulgar pleasures with which
they fill their souls. Over these men
stand an immense tudorary power which
assumes sole responsibility for securing
their pleasures and watching over their
fate." Think about the society that we
live in today. The entire world. Before
we were asked to sacrifice ourselves for
civilization. Before we were asked to
um be great to work together. Now we're
asked to just buy things. Buying things
will make us happy and it's
responsibility of the government to
ensure we can buy things. Okay? That's
the world we live in today.
It's is impossible to believe that a
liberal, energetic, and wise government
can ever emerge from the balance of a
nation of servants. If you're a
consumer, if all you're concerned is
buying things, you are just a
slave. The possibility of a constitution
being republican in its head and ultra
monarchal in all its other parts has
always struck me as an enthermal
monster. Okay, we think we live in
democracy. We think the government
listens to us, but it's really the
imperial bureaucracy that's in charge
and that's a monster. The vice of those
who govern and the imbecility of the
govern would quickly bring about its
ruin and the people tired of their
representatives and of themselves would
either create free institutions or soon
return to prostrating themselves at the
fate at the feet of a single master.
Okay. So this is a prophecy. The
prophecy is this America the way it is
structured the way it is conceived is
not sustainable in the long term. Either
it will break apart in a civil war or a
tyrant will
emerge. It will become a monarchy. Okay.
That is the dark prophecy for America.
Okay. So um America is again in
competition with these other
civilizations. All right. So what I will
do now is just summarize what we've
learned to give you a broad framework
for understanding the nature of American
society.
Okay.
Sorry. All
right. So So I I apologize. I I I know
that today was very fast. Um but let me
just summarize what we've learned and
you have a much clearer idea
um of the ideas today. All right. So
before the focus on civilization, what
is civilization? It is a
history,
culture, values. Okay. And before
everyone understood the purpose of your
life was to maintain, protect and defend
your civilization.
Okay. But there's there's certain
problems with civilization that emerges
over time. The first of course is the
idea of prejudice. You just believe that
you your civilization is superior to
that of other civilizations. Okay.
Everyone believes this. Um my
civilization is better and I will and I
my civilization is superior to yours. So
this leads this is prejudice. It leads
to
war, violence. It leads to
um lack of innovation. Openness, right?
Is it stubbornness,
inflexibility? It also limits
immigration. Okay, does that make sense?
Okay, this is the nature of civilization
throughout most of human history. Now,
this is a problem for America. Why?
Because as I mentioned, America was
founded
by immigrants.
Right. It's was it was it's it's also
pretty
diverse. Diversity,
openness, and um so these are the three
characteristics of America. It's a very
diverse place with different religions,
different cultures. It's always trying
to welcome immigrants in order to build
up its nation and wealth. And it has to
be open because it needs to steal ideas
from Europe basically. All right. So now
you have a problem.
Right? Civilization cannot solve these
problems. So what do you do in order to
create a society? What you do is rather
than build a civilization, you create a
game. Okay? In many ways, America is an
anti-vilivilization. It's trying to
remedy the failings and weaknesses of
civilizations in the past. It's decided,
we're going to create a game, guys.
Okay, that's the idea of the US
Constitution. What's the game? The game
is this. First of all, we need to have
game masters. Game masters is the
government. And but the problem is for
the game to work, it has to be
fair. It has to be
clean. Okay? It has to be winnable for
people. Does that make sense? You only
play games if you think the game is fair
and it's winnable and it's rewarding,
right?
It's transparent. Therefore, our
government must be fair, transparent,
and democratic to get as many people to
play this game as possible. All right.
Once the government is in place, now
what we do is we create the rules for
the game that are
um fair, just and which is winnable.
Okay. So the purpose of this game is to
make as much money as possible. Okay?
Material
acquisition. If you win this money, it's
yours. Okay? Private
property by law. Whatever you earn,
whatever is whatever you have earned is
yours forever. It's yours. It's yours.
But it's also your children's. Okay? You
understand? This is a game that America
has constructed.
If you think about it, this is great
because now you can bring in as many
immigrants as you want because all they
do is play this game. Everyone wants to
play this game. Allows you to be open
because it allows for rapid innovation
within your society. Okay? It allows for
diversity as well because everyone's
striving to make as much money as
possible. Okay? So that's what America
is. America sees itself as a new
civilization, but it's really an
anti-alivilization because it's really a
game. And over time, what will happen is
because America has become more and more
wealthy, it will be able to conquer the
world and establish the game throughout
the world. In China today, we are
playing this game, right? What what do
we believe? We believe that we come to
school because we need to get an
education, go to America, get a degree
so that we can become rich. When we
become rich, we can buy things, right?
You're playing this game. We've all been
brainwashed to play this
game.
Okay? The problem with this game is
eventually the
few will win everything. Does that make
sense? jump massive
inequality in the world. And when this
happens, people are like, "This game
sucks. What do we do now?" And then
people will be like, "You know
what? I miss civilization. I miss when
it was clear what my identity was. When
it was clear what I had to do in life,
when I was asked to make sacrifices for
the greater good. I miss that. I'm
nostalgic for that." Okay. And of
course, this is what gives us
MAGA, right? Ultimately, MAGA is about
trying
to restore the idea of civilization in
America. Make America great again. Make
America into a white
Christian democratic nation again. Let
us restore the vision of Thomas
Jefferson.
Right? Okay, that's it. So this is just
an introduction to America. We will
continue this topic as we move further
and further along the course. Okay. So
next week we will do uh the German and
Russian civilizations. What you will see
is that in many ways these civilizations
are far superior to the
Anglo-American Empire. All
right. So any questions?
Okay.